It's official: Apple has become the first 1-trillion-dollar publicly-listed US company.
Started in Steve Jobs' garage in 1976,...
...Apple evolved from selling Mac personal computers...
...to launching the iPhone in 2007...
...and becoming an architect of the mobile revolution.
Along the way, it developed a cult-like following.
Its stock has surged more than 50,000 percent since its 1980 initial public offering.
Now, Apple's stock market value...
...is greater than those of Exxon Mobil, Procter & Gamble and AT&T combined.
The iPhone maker has also pushed its revenue...
...beyond the economic outputs of Portugal, New Zealand, and other countries.
But global demand for smartphones is losing steam.
Analysts say, Apple could lose its lead to the likes of Alphabet or Amazon...
...if it doesn't find a major new product or service soon.